en
blanc tout cas déjà avoir intégré les
prêts pandémie de la fed américaine à la
bce en passant par la banque
d'angleterre l'heure est au serrage de
vis après des années de largesses les
grands banque centrale entame la
normalisation des politiques monétaires
notamment aux états unis mais comment
agir sur les vannes du crédit sans peser
sur une croissance qui s'essouffle déjà
c'est le dilemme des banques centrales
et on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir c'est l'édito
échos
bonsoir rac merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france encore un petit peu
à distance la semaine prochaine on aura
le plaisir de vous avoir à nouveau en
plateau jacques après donc cessé et non
au sein de ces derniers jours va t-on
vers la fin de l'argent facile celui des
versets notamment par les banques
centrales
oui c'est fini il est clair que l'on va
assister un changement assez profond des
politiques des banques centrales la
réserve fédérale américaine par exemple
a été appliquée il faut s'attendre
désormais à trois voire quatre
resserrement des taux pour 2022 et
surtout la baisse de ce que l'on appelle
le bilan de l'établissement pour la
vente des titres qui ont été achetés en
masse depuis deux ans en fait il faut
toujours rappeler que depuis le début de
la crise sanitaire la taille du bilan de
la fed a doublé alors la bce quand elle
l est plus prudente les achats de titres
liés à la pandémie vont néanmoins se
réduire progressivement au premier
semestre et christine lagarde a été
quand même plus évasif sur la
perspective de hausses de taux les
banques centrales doivent naviguer vous
l'avait dit entre la crainte que la
hausse de l'inflation ne s'accélère et
le fait que l'ex perspectives de la
croissance dans de nombreux pays de
l'union européenne eh bien elles ont été
révisées à la baisse est tout d'abord
jacques où on est on est des engagements
de ces banques
alors stéphanie ses engagements ils
peuvent être suivis tout simplement par
l'évolution des dettes alors c'est le
déminage celle des entreprises non
financières est aussi celle des états
l'ont l'endettement des agents vie non
financiers privés autrement dit les
ménages et les entreprises à augmenter
de manière significative durant la crise
sanitaire c'est le résultat justement
des politiques de soutien qui ont été
mises en place par les différentes
banques centrales ces dernières ont
racheté des titres de dette pas
seulement ceux des états cloud toujours
l'indiqué mais aussi ceux des
entreprises ces rachats par ailleurs ils
ont été plus ou moins importants suivant
les pays si vous prenez par exemple les
états unis et l'allemagne est bien le
mouvement d'endettement des entreprises
durant la pandémie a été relativement
faible par contre si vous prenez le cas
au japon de la france du royaume uni et
bien là on voit que le mouvement il a
été nettement plus élevé les bilans des
banques centrales sont donc très mini de
l'an chargé de titres d'entreprises mais
aussi évidemment d'obligations publiques
comme vous l'avez souligné à les dettes
publiques ont aussi largement augmenté
mais normalement c'est d'être honoré par
intel pas dû se retrouver dans dans les
comptes des banques centrales
effectivement c'est fini daisy ya quand
même pas mal de marge entre la théorie
et la pratique on fait même la banque
centrale européenne à racheter des
obligations d'état alors bien sûr elle
n'hésite pas à racheter directement au
gouvernement sur ce qu'on appelle le
marché primaire mais elle les a rachetés
aux banques de plus à travers le ppp le
fameux fonds d'urgence créé pour lutter
contre la pandémie et bien la bce a pu
racheter directement des obligations
d'état ceci a aussi été rendu possible
par la baisse des taux ainsi même si le
taux à 10 ans sur les obligations
publiques françaises est redevenu
positif du coût de l'endettement
globalement est toujours très faible et
tout cela ne va pas durer
oui naturellement non stéphanie
naturellement dont les pressions pour
que les banques centrales reviennent à
des politiques plus restrictives
celle d'avant la crise par exemple se
multiplient on peut le comprendre la
hausse de l'inflation et de 7% aux
etats-unis de 5 4% en allemagne bref une
partie de l'opinion publique qui réclame
désormais des politiques plus respirer
plus restrictive mais ce n'est pas la
seule raison en fait la politique des
banques centrales elle a provoqué une
forme de croyance chez les investisseurs
leur investissement désormais aider
complètement garanti c'est une des
raisons qui expliquent les performances
tout à fait étincelante des bourses
durant l'année qui vient de s'écouler
alors c'est un comportement malsain et
ça remet tout ça le à le constater et à
le déplorer et c'est ce qui explique
évidemment la volonté des banques
centrales de changer de politique et la
question est que vont-elles faire
alors elles peuvent utiliser et elles
vont utiliser en réalité deux
instruments le premier va être de ces
c'est justement d'acheter ces titres
voire de revendre une partie des titres
qu'elles détiennent pour faire dégonfler
leur bilan le second va consister en des
hausses régulières des taux
d'intervention ce qu'on appelle
classiquement les taux directeurs alors
si on prend le cas de la réserve
fédérale cette dernière annonce et un
dégonflement rapide de son bilan et la
perspective d'au moins trois housses de
taux pour 2022 est cependant pas du tout
impossible que la pression monte sur la
réserve fédérale et qu'elle procède en
réalité à 91,2 tôt cette année la bce
quant à elle prévoit un arrêt du
programme d'urgence le fameux ppp au
premier trimestre de 2022 oui devant
l'importance de l'inflation la main et
devant la réaction évidemment que d'une
partie de l'opinion publique allemande
face à cette inflation est bien il est
probable qu'elle sera malgré tout obligé
d'accélérer ces mesures restrictives et
tout ceci aura évidemment des
conséquences vac
oui évidemment c'est à 10 compte tenu du
niveau d'endettement de tous les agents
les entreprises les ménages si l'état
les banques centrales sont condamnés à
être très prudents si lé fils trop fort
ou trop brutalement elle risque de
provoquer une montée de l'insolvabilité
des agents non financiers qui ont mieux
de compromettre la croissance si elles
agissent trop faiblement leurs actions
risquent de ne pas avoir le poids
nécessaire pour modifier justement les
comportements marche d'action et donc et
3 mais ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
les pressions des politiques et d'une
partie de l'opinion publique pour que
les banques centrales resserrent le
crédit vont être appelés à monter au
moins dans le premier semestre de
l'année 2022 de quoi sera faite cette
année
il écrire stéphanie que nous aurons un
changement de politique de la part des
banques centrales avec une hausse
générale des taux mais la vraie question
c'est est-ce que les banques centrales
seront elles libres d'agir comme elle le
souhaitait donc de maintenir quand même
une certaine prudence ou bien pourront
elles se plier à des pressions
politiques d'autre part dans quelle
mesure l'économie mondiale
réagira-t-elle à des politiques
monétaires qui vont s'avérer être très
divergentes je croyais avoir déjà une
divergence entre la politique monétaire
aux états unis et la politique monétaire
dans l'union européenne politique
monétaire de la bce mais ils aillent
aussi y avoir une divergence importante
entre les etats-unis et la chine où la
banque centrale vient quant à elle de
baisser son taux directeur ce qui
complètement à contre courant de ce qui
est fait ailleurs ce type de divergence
vannes évidemment impliquée une très
grande volatilité des taux de change
merci jacques pour ses mises en garde et
à la semaine prochaine pour un nouvel
édito merci à vous